[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and in this video we
will be explaining all ten members of
the ten commandments the main
antagonists of seven of these sins
season two and their powers thank you so
much for the support you've shown on our
every seven deadly sin explained video
we had a bunch of people actually
thanked us for making seven deadly sins
content here on the channel I really
enjoy making these videos and doing more
research on the seven deadly sins
characters they really are such unique
interesting characters and it was a lot
of fun since you guys have all shown so
much support you can expect a lot more
seven deadly sins content on this
channel thank you again
big thank you to Briggs from all-day
anime for helping me double check some
of the facts in this video he has made a
bunch of seven deadly sins videos on his
channel and he is making weekly episode
reviews for season two so be sure to
check them out link in the description
if you enjoyed these videos I want to
see more be sure to leave a like to let
me know if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell if you want to support
this channel and get cool anime merch at
the same time you can check out our
merch store link in the description and
of course we are now posting daily anime
content on Twitter and Instagram you can
follow us at anime uproar just to give
you a quick warning there will
definitely be spoilers about the 10
commandments in this video however I'm
gonna do my best to only talk about each
member's backstory and powers without
revealing what actually happens to them
in the story with that said if you're
one of those people that doesn't like
any spoilers whatsoever you have been
warned the Ten Commandments are the 10
strongest warriors of the demon clan
selected by the demon king as a demon
special forces unit of sorts however it
is important to note that not all
members of the ten commandments were
born into the demon clan some were
originally members of other races the
demon king who is the ruler of the
entire demon clan separated half of his
power into ten
he says and gave each piece to one of
these ten warriors as a result each
warrior has a unique commandment a
special power that can put a curse on
whoever breaks the specific rule or
commandment that this warrior possesses
some of these Commandments do have
similarities to the ten commandments of
the judeo-christian religious traditions
like in the Bible but they do not
correspond exactly to them and they are
not a one-to-one match each member of
the commandments is immune to the
commandments of others but they must not
violate their own commandment the Ten
Commandments fought against the four
other clans during the holy war 3,000
years ago and their leader at the time
was meliodas
the current dragon's sin of Wrath but
Mele Yoda's turned against the
commandments betrayed in the demon clan
and eventually the Ten Commandments were
sealed inside the coffin of eternal
darkness just like the rest of the
demons they were released by fraud Rijn
a demon who was sealed away separately
from the other demons and who managed to
escape his seal 16 years earlier when it
was broken by some humans he then used
Elizabeth's blood to open the coffin of
eternal darkness but he needed more of
Elizabeth's blood in order to release
the entire demon clan and he only had a
little bit that was left over on a piece
of cloth as a result Roger was able to
release the rest of the Ten Commandments
but not the entire demon clan at the
time of their release the magical powers
of the Ten Commandments are depleted and
in order to recover their magic they
need to eat the souls of humans I will
talk more about fraudulent in a little
bit as he is currently a member of the
ten commandments but first let's talk
about Zell drous Zell drous is the piety
of the Ten Commandments and he is the
youngest son of the demon king and the
current leader of the ten commandments
Zell drous is currently acting as the
demon Kings representative he is the
younger brother of Mel Yoda's and has a
very similar appearance to meliodas and
even a similar voice although his
clothing and hair are different and his
demon mark is on the other side of his
for
zel dress is cool and calculating by
nature and he has strong leadership
skills but because he is very loyal to
his family and the demon clan
melioidosis betrayal infuriated him and
he wants to get revenge on Mellie Otis
and all the other clans zelgius
commandment is piety and according to
this commandment whoever turns his back
to zelgius is considered a traitor and
is cursed into becoming a servant of the
demon king and since zell drous is the
Kings representative whoever turns his
back on zell drous is cursed
to serve Him Zell dresses desire is to
become the demon king himself and like
all the other demons he has the power to
generate darkness from his body and use
it to create things like weapons or even
wings he is extremely strong fast and
resilient and he is able to take the
force of some of the most powerful
attacks without sustaining significant
damage as the leader and the demon Kings
representative zelgius is able to
contact the other members of the ten
commandments through telepathy and he is
able to remove a commandment from a
current member and give it to someone
else if he chooses Zell drusus innate
power is the power granted to him
directly by the demon king also known as
the power of God like Mel Yoda's he can
use the demonic power known as hell
blaze which creates powerful black
flames that can harm even an immortal
being without them being able to
regenerate and he also has the ability
known as Desiree which lets him create a
portal to a specific target and strike
that target down with a lightning bolt
his weapon of choice is a short sword
next up is esta rosa the love of the Ten
Commandments another son of the demon
king and the second brother of Mellie
Otis esta rosa is older than Zell dress
but younger than meliodas
he is cold and ruthless and although he
has some physical similarities to his
brothers and he looks almost identical
to Mellie Otis's wanted poster esta rosa
is much taller than both of his brothers
he once greatly admired his older
brother Mellie Otis precisely because as
the former leader of the ten
commandments
Mellie Otis was cruel and ruthless
against his enemies but after Mellie
betrayed the 10 commandments esta rosa
began to deeply resent his brother for
turning his back on his own family and
clan esta roses commandment is love and
according to this commandment whoever
stands before esta rosa with hatred in
his heart will lose their power and
become helpless this is an extremely
effective commandment in my opinion
since hating one's enemy is such a
common human characteristic all those
eldress is the leader of the ten
commandments esta rosa is believed to be
even stronger than Zell drous and he is
shown to be able to put up a bigger
fight against Mele Oda's in assault mode
than zelgius could and he is also able
to turn living beings into demons as is
the case with the drinking of demon
blood some who are turned into demons by
Esther osa will survive and others won't
be able to handle the power and their
bodies will explode unsurprisingly esta
rosa is incredibly strong fast and
resilient in battle and can withstand
the power of some of the most powerful
attacks like his brother meliodas esta
rosa possesses the ability to use full
counter
but while melioidosis ability is to
counter magical attacks as therosis
ability allows him to counter physical
attacks and direct them back at his
opponent with even more power than the
original attack esta Rosa's weapon of
choice is an ability known as rebellion
swords which allows him to create seven
black swords and use them against his
enemies then we have derrière II the
purity of the Ten Commandments a female
demon whose name will definitely be
appreciated by French speakers derriere
II appears to wear no clothes and she
covers her private parts with her
demonic darkness although she is
normally calm and apathetic she does
have a temper she feels a special
animosity towards the goddess clan as
they were responsible for killing her
sister and she is known to lose her cool
whenever the goddess clan is involved
without giving away too many spoilers
Guerrieri is definitely an interesting
character who develops in unique ways as
the story progresses the Aries
commandment is purity however we do not
know what the conditions or
Effects of Herr commandant our sensor
commandment is purity I wonder if her
power has something to do with impure
thoughts so for example if you are in
her presence and you have impure
thoughts about her body you become
cursed seeing as how she wears no
clothing
if impure thoughts are indeed part of
her commandment let's face it we would
all be pretty screwed way to Opie dairy
area is known for her physical combat
capability and hand-to-hand battle
tactics and the speed with which she is
able to launch her attacks is
astonishing even compared to an
incredibly strong character like Mellie
Otis her innate power is combo star
which allows her to keep increasing the
power of her attacks each time she is
able to land a hit without interruption
so essentially the bigger the combo of
hits that she can land the stronger her
next attack will be she also has the
ability to sacrifice 6 over 7 demon
hearts in order to transform into Endora
the beast of destruction
this transformation increases her power
but at the price of her ability to think
rationally so it becomes a type of
Berserker mode transformation next up is
Mon speed the reticence of the ten
commandments as his gentlemanly
appearance suggests Mon speed is a male
demon who takes special pride in having
proper manners and he is known to
dislike rudeness he has a special
connection with derriere II and he is
always by her side Mon speeds
commandment is reticence and reticence
essentially means being reserved not
speaking unless necessary and not taking
things in vain just like with derriere e
we don't have any specific information
about the conditions or effects of his
commandment it might be connected to
thinking things through before acting
and not taking actions prematurely or in
vain but we just don't know this
commandment could be inspired by the
real commandment to not take the Lord's
name in vain by the way while it's
disappointing that we don't know what
all of the Ten Commandments do if you
have your own theories for what some of
the unknown
Commandments do let me know down in the
comments on top of the powers that all
demons have such as generating demonic
darkness once Pete is able to sense
powerful enemies from hundreds of miles
away and he can accurately send an
attack at his enemies from a great
distance such as when he uses his Goku
encho ability which produces a strong
flame shaped like a bird that homes it
on his enemies and flies at them with
great destructive force
he is extremely fast even compared to
other fast characters and he has high
levels of endurance the name of Monts
Pete's innate magic is trick star and
along with a bird shaped flame he can
also create powerful flames in the shape
of other beasts such as a dragon and
used them in his attacks like derrière E
Mon speed is also shown to be capable of
performing the Endura transformation and
then of course we have fraud reigned the
selflessness of the ten commandments a
demon who has been possessing the body
of Dreyfus for the last ten years
fraud Rijn is not an original member of
the ten commandments rather he is a
replacement for a demon by the name of
gold gold there was made a member of the
ten commandments against his will by the
demon king because the demon king wanted
to take advantage of gold there's great
magical abilities but both are
eventually deserted the ten commandments
by the way this is not the same goal as
older the gold sin of lust but the demon
Golder is the one who created the doll
we know as Goethe er so go through the
demon is the creator of the goal thir
who is now a member of the seven deadly
sins back to froderick
during the holy war a goddess had sealed
him away separately from the other
demons some time before the other demons
were sealed away and fraud Rijn managed
to escape his seal sixteen years before
the start of the story because his seal
was broken by some humans he manages to
possess the body of Dreyfuss and use it
as a vessel to get revenge Emily odors
for betraying the demon clan first he
frames the seven deadly sins for
murder of Zara trois and then he tries
to execute his ultimate plan which is to
open the coffin of eternal darkness and
resurrect the demon clan after getting
Hendrickson to release the rest of the
ten commandments from the coffin of
eternal darkness fraud Rijn actually
lets Hendrickson go free this is just
one of a number of occasions in which we
see fraudulent showing some form of
compassion towards certain humans and
this characteristic stems from the fact
that he spent so many years inside the
body of Dreyfus because he spent so many
years inside of Dreyfus fraudulent ended
up absorbing some of his human
compassion especially towards people
close to Dreyfus like his sangria mori
but despite this Rajan is often boastful
and he can also be very cruel and
malicious especially towards meliodas as
he had waited and flooded for years to
get revenge on him fraud runes
commandment of selflessness appears to
have such an effect that whoever in his
presence harbors feelings of selfishness
and greed will lose his memories and
eventually his whole sense of self like
the other members of the ten
commandments he is extremely strong and
difficult to defeat although the fact
that he is a replacement for a missing
member of the commandment seems to make
him somewhat inferior to the other
full-fledged members along with the
ability to possess the bodies of others
and access their abilities while in
their body fraud Hrant is also able to
return to his full demon size which not
only makes him humongous but also
increases his power and strength next up
is malice Kula the faith of the ten
commandments a female demon that often
covers herself with her demonic darkness
malice Kula is 362 years old not
counting the time she spent sealed away
but in classic anime fashion she still
looks like a lolly for some reason to
make things even better her true form is
that of a snake and in her human form
she has a snake-like long tongue making
her a three hundred and sixty
two-year-old snake lolly in terms of
personality she often appears bored
Andras
but when it comes time to battle she is
known to be boastful and to mark her
opponents masculist commandment is faith
and it has such an effect that whoever
shows faithlessness before her will have
his eyes set on fire
malice Kula is amused by the fact that
people who have deeply held beliefs and
principles often portray those beliefs
as soon as they are faced with a
challenge meaning they become faithless
very easily and she sees this as a sign
of their weakness malice Kula can use
her demonic darkness to wrap herself
into a protective cocoon that can keep
her safe from extremely powerful attacks
she also has the ability to manipulate
the dead and to some and less powerful
demons such as the red and grey demons
on top of that mulaskey Allah can
transform into a giant snake and this
transformation increases her power even
further and it also allows her to spew
toxic venom lastly she is able to open
magical portals that she can use for
various purposes then we have gloxinia
the repose of the ten commandments
speaking of Lolly's the next member of
the ten commandments is a male tentacle
lolli sort of he is actually a 1400 year
old fairy and the former king of the
fairy Kings Forest but at some point he
allied himself with the demon clan and
eventually became a demon himself the
green octopus that surrounds him is in
fact the spirit spear boskie oz which is
the special weapon he had been granted
as the fairy King just like Kings spirit
spear chaste aful Bastia can take many
different forms including the form of a
green octopus consistent with his fairy
background gloxinia has great magical
power but not much physical strength as
a demon gloxinia has a sadistic nature
and he harbors a particular hatred
towards humans we still don't know the
conditions and effects of his
commandment repose although repose means
to rest or sleep so it is likely
referring to the biblical religious
commandment to keep the seventh-day
or the Sabbath a day of rest and prayer
like King gloxinia can fly and he
possesses the ability disaster which
allows him to control nature through the
use of his spirit spear stemming from
his ability to control nature gloxinia
can create various monsters from the
earth and used them for his own ends and
this is on top of many other abilities
that relate in some way to nature and
earth manipulation next up is droll
the patience of the ten commandments
droll was originally a giant but he
differs from the other Giants because he
is even larger than the average giant
his skin is blue and he has four arms
instead of two he was an important
figure in the history of the giant clan
and he is credited with inventing the
sacred dance of the Giants above all
other things he greatly values physical
strength and his primary Drive in life
was always his pride and honor as a
warrior after he was defeated by zelgius
in battle drôle felt humiliated and he
decided to follow Zell drous join the 10
commandments and become a demon himself
he is another character that undergoes
quite a bit of development as the story
goes on drawls commandment is patience
but we still don't know its effects or
condition along with the regular demonic
abilities drools immense size gives him
incredible physical strength and
endurance and he is able to withstand
some of the most powerful attacks with
relative ease even though his sizes
massive drol is still both quick and
agile and he is believed to be the
strongest giant that we have seen to
date as a giant troll has the ability to
control the earth in a similar way that
Diane does with her ability creation but
drawls ability is even stronger and more
developed he can use the earth to create
weapons and golems and because he has a
deeper connection with the earth than
less experienced Giants he can negate
the creation power of other Giants drol
also has the ability to measure the
strength and power of an opponent just
by looking at them and he is even able
to read their mind malleolus is the
only person whom drool cannot seem to
read but we're not sure why then we have
gray road the pacifism of the ten
commandments gray road is a gray demon
that underwent a grotesque mutation
although refer to as female gray road
doesn't really have a gender per se and
her body is made up of multiple smaller
gray demons her commandant is pacifism
and as a result of the commandment
anyone who kills in gray roads presence
will lose their own lifespan and begin
aging quickly until they die along with
the usual demonic powers gray road is
capable of flight and of creating new
demons by implanting living creatures
with a demon seed and then trapping them
inside pods once the demon eggs hatch
these demons will serve gray road
in addition gray road can change her
appearance to look like her opponent in
battle
lastly gray road is able to curse her
enemies to make them sick and unable to
battle without killing them directly and
this is important because that way she
doesn't violate her own commandment
which is essentially thou shalt not kill
and finally we have Galland the truth of
the ten commandments
Galland is a demon whose actual demon
body looks just like the armor of a
knight
he loves violence and battling strong
opponents and he has fun fighting
destroying and playing violent games but
this cavalier attitude sometimes
backfires as he underestimates his
opponents kelan's commandment of truth
ensures that anyone who lies in front of
him turns into stone as long as they are
lying willingly and not because they
simply don't have the accurate
information along with the usual demonic
powers Galland
is known for his great physical strength
and speed his speed in particular is so
incredible that it can outrun the spells
of even the most powerful magicians the
name of his innate power is critical /
and it allows him to unlock the full
extent of his physical strength his
weapon of choice is a double-sided spear
and he is capable of using
with great effectiveness in a variety of
deadly ways and that is it all ten
current members of the ten commandments
at the beginning of seven deadly sins
season to the known former members of
the ten commandments include calm adios
a massive demon with six arms who was
eventually replaced by zeldron as piety
we also have the demon known as golfer
who as mentioned earlier decided to
abandon the Ten Commandments after which
he was replaced by fraud Rijn as
selflessness
there were also are anak and Zeno who
were both killed by meliodas after his
betrayal of the demon clan 3,000 years
ago and of course we have meliodas
himself who was once the leader of the
ten commandments before turning against
them I really hope that you guys enjoyed
this video and that you will find it
useful to have all of this information
in one place if you made it all the way
through the video you can drop a hashtag
snake lolly down in the comments to let
me know as I mentioned earlier I'm
really enjoying getting back into the
seven deadly sins manga and all the
stuff around it so thank you so much for
all the support you've shown for these
videos and don't worry more content is
on the way if you do enjoy these videos
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell if you want to keep up with all the
latest happenings on the channel be sure
to follow us on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar both links are in the
description as always thank you all so
much for watching thank you for all the
support and the kind words and until
next time see us bass cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]